alors comment endiguer cette cinquième
vague en france et ses conséquences
parfois dramatiques quand même constaté
nouvelle série de mesures annoncées par
le gouvernement ce soir est elle
vraiment suffisant pour mettre fin à la
propagation les cours d'école désormais
lieu de contamination place au
décryptage
est avec moi pour en parler ce soir
bruno m'égare ban chef du service
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris bonsoir d'auteur merci d'être avec
nous à nos côtés franck delvaux
restaurateurs co président de l'umih
paris-ile-de-france bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous franquin delvaux enfin nicolas
landi coordinateur du collectif parents
atterré bonsoir à vous également merci
d'être là une petite réaction avons
évidemment de par les nouvelles mesures
annoncées par olivier ferrand et jean
castex ce soir une réaction sur ce
témoignage assez poignant qu'on a vu de
virginie meyer on parle assez peu ducobu
dont vous nous avez un petit peu par les
uns d'ailleurs de cela docteur de temps
en temps c'est quand même fréquence ce
type de symptômes ça fait un an que
cette femme qui était sportive ne peut
plus courir qu'elle est fatiguée qu'elle
ne peut plus travailler alors qu'on
estime à peu près 10% des personnes qui
ont fait la queue vide par une infection
naturelles auront des symptômes qui vont
persister au-delà du troisième mois
alors on ne sait pas y'a pas de facteurs
qui prédisent le risque c'est une
personne qui fait réellement l'infection
il faut à nouveau le rappeler sont des
personnes qui font une infection
mineurs c'est pas des personnes qui
viennent en rénovation eux qui auront
devrait complications et séquelles qui
sont attribués à la gravité de leur
maladie ici en fait aux très
probablement à l'occasion de cette
infection par le sar skov 2 il va y
avoir une certaine inflammation de
certaines structures cérébrales qui vont
être responsable de symptômes diverses
c'est pourquoi le tableau est très
polymorphe d'ailleurs certains le
mettant en cause en dix ans c'est plutôt
psychosomatique mais des explorations
extrêmement sérieuses montrent des
éléments objectifs d'atteinte de
structures neurologique centrale à
l'origine de ces symptômes
heureusement beaucoup de ces symptômes
sont spontanément régressif avec le
temps et il se pourrait même que la
vaccination que l'on fait après avoir
été infectés accélère cette réversion on
va parler à maintenant évidemment ces
restrictions on a entendu les deux
ministres ce soir face à cette
résurgence en tout cas voici donc un
aperçu des annonces du gouvernement les
plus de 65 ans qui pourront accéder aux
rappels de vaccins sans rendez-vous
fermeture des discothèques pendant
quatre semaines l'ouverture de la
vaccination visage et pour tous les
enfants de 5 à 11 ans on va les détails
et avec vous messieurs mais tout d'abord
une question encore au docteur meyer ban
cette vaccination ouverts aux plus de 65
ans sont rendez vous ça va changer
quelque chose selon vous parce qu'on on
parle tout le temps de ces personnes
âgées on ne vient pas chercher sur
l'homme dans leur maison pour venir se
faire vacciner est ce que cela ça va
changer c'était la bonne mesure ce soir
alors on va discuter tout à l'heure mais
le gouvernement a pris finalement très
peu de mesures restrictives a fait
beaucoup de pédagogie et et souhaite
responsabiliser la population en termes
de respect des mesures barrières mais il
a choisi quand même deux armes
essentielles la première c'est la
vaccination des enfants on en reparlera
mais aussi cette dose de rappels chez
tous les adultes à partir du cinquième
mois après la double dose alors on va
dire la diminution de protection avec le
temps à partir de la double vaccination
est atteint la totalité des personnes
mais néanmoins cette protection devient
plus problématique chez les personnes
les plus âgées les plus fragiles avec
des comorbidités il est donc tout à fait
logique de permettre aux personnes de
plus de 65 ans de bénéficier de cette
dose de rappel le plus rapidement
possible car lorsqu'on regarde les
patients doublement vaccinés qui sont
admis à l'hôpital ou en réanimation
c'est essentiellement des personnes
âgées ou immunodéprimées
alors on va regarder une première
réaction à celle de marine le pen
forcément dans l'opposition et pas
forcément contente on s'en doute à côté
de la plaque dit elle
castex préfère punir des enfants
innocents en imposant le masque en
extérieur à l'école plutôt que mettre en
place des purificateurs d'air en des
tests gratuits pour tous sont encore
réintégré les 1000 he les 15000
soignants suspendu alors il est vrai que
beaucoup de mesures concerne nos enfants
un nicolas landi 1 notamment le port du
masque ça y est on s'y retrouve aussi à
l'extérieur à nos bambins avec le masque
sur la bouche on parlera aussi de la
vaccination envisagée pour tous les
enfants de 5 à 11 ans et ce à partir du
20 décembre sont la base du volontariat
pour les plus fragiles ce sera ouvert a
évidemment en priorité un nicolas l'on
dit une réaction sur ces mesures qui
concernent principalement les enfants ce
soir
donc je voulais dire j'avais été
particulièrement touché par le
témoignage de la personne touchée par un
kobe de l'eau
pompée espère sa pompe son compteur
établissement c'est important de le dire
parce que aujourd'hui il ya d'autres
personnes qui sont touchées par d'autres
formes de co vivions ce sont les ans le
comme il est long très long pour les
enfants je vous rappelle que sont les
prix parce que totalement de l'odorat
pendant des heures par jour quand ils
sont masqués hyper de l'acuité visuelle
parce qu'ils ont beaucoup de mal à
mettre leurs lunettes donc va pas voir
leur correction visuelle ils ont eu
aussi des troubles cognitifs parce que
parents pour leur apprendre à lire et à
écrire c'est très difficile et ne lis
pas sur les lèvres de leurs enseignants
sur les ailes d'or camarades les moyens
de communication non verbale bas ils en
sont aussi privés pour l'essentiel leur
psychisme est atteint tout ça s'est
avéré donc les effets du comics sont
très très longue pour les enfants et
donc pas cette mesure pour nous elle est
assez loufoque on les arts masqué vous
souvenez que 45% des départements
avaient levé l'obligation du masque
entre octobre et novembre de novembre on
a vu les remet à ce qu'est et puis là il
ya effectivement une augmentation forte
des taux de de contamination chez les
petits ont leur ne discute pas parce que
l'on fait énormément de talent chez les
petits et beaucoup moins chez les
adultes puisque j'avais lu c'est payant
et et malgré le masque et bien ces taux
augmente beaucoup donc bah il avait plus
que le moment de la récré pour respirer
basse et fils est fichu
alors que l'on sait parfaitement que la
probabilité d'attraper les coville à
l'extérieur est divisé par 20 par
rapport à l'intérieur donc ça c'est la
première mesure que la deuxième mesure
qui va venir très vite c'est on va sans
doute nous dire que la vaccination des
petits est obligatoire et allons-y donc
alors que c'est la responsabilité des
parents de décider de quelle manière ils
vont protéger leurs enfants je ne vois
pas quel est l'intérêt de faire vacciner
les petits d'eau peu oui encore une
consternation encore une fois il faut
montrer un activisme alors que dans la
pandémie cours on est proche du pic de
2020 on n'est pas content tu vas bientôt
s'approcher du pic de 2010 2020 avril
2020 on a cette chance qu'il ya beaucoup
moins de morts par contre parce
qu'effectivement
les vaccins les vaccins ont montré une
efficacité
on va quand même pas c'est aussi la
parole aux autres invités on a bien en
tout cas compris merci de votre clarté
bruno mega man
voilà on entend de ce parent un petit
peu voire désole de voir encore les
enfants c'est vrai être entre guillemets
ciblés par ces mesures est ce bien
nécessaire encore beaucoup de français
pensent que les plus fragiles ne sont
pas les enfants ça veut dire quoi que le
doivent trinquer pour protéger les
autres et notamment les non vaccinés
alors on va dire monsieur a bien
souligné que les enfants peuvent être
atteints par la coved 19 avec parfois
des ennuis assez important d'abord vous
en voyez beaucoup alors moi je ne
m'occupe que d'adultes donc
mais effectivement aujourd'hui c'est le
la classe d'âge où circule le plus fort
taux de
2,2 de virus quasiment le double de
l'incidence dans la population générale
l'institut pasteur avait prédit que 50%
des contaminations au cours de cette
vague se feront chez les enfants
pourquoi parce que le virus circule
préférentiellement celle et les
personnes non vaccinées et là on a une
classe d'âge entière
qui est pas du tout vacciner peu
immunisés et donc évidemment c'est le
terreau favori de circulation du virus
donc de fait effectivement il faut être
un peu plus prudent alors je suis
d'accord que le masque dans la cour de
récréation c'est pas le moyen radical
pour lutter là dessus par contre je
pense que la vaccination sera très utile
car il n'y a aucune raison qu'elle ne
soit mal toléré il n'y a aucune raison
qu'elle soit à qu'elle s'accompagne
d'effets secondaires plus important que
chez les adultes à l'inversé n'est
parfaitement efficace elle permettra de
réduire la circulation du virus dans
cette classe d'âge est de permettre un
bénéfice direct aux enfants c'est ça le
plus important c'est ce qu'a expliqué
monsieur c'est à dire ils ne tomberont
pas malade il ne développeront pas de
kovy de long ils n'auront pas de
syndrome inflammatoire important et
surtout ils pourront suivre une
scolarité normale et ne pas servir de
vecteur de transmission du virus à des
adultes de leur entourage plus fragile
plus âgés éventuellement avec
immunosuppression et donc c'est ainsi
qu'on va pouvoir maîtriser la
circulation du virus alors je vais me
retourner vers vous quand même franck
delvaux et coprésident de 2 mais paris
ile de france on n'a pas parlé de
restaurant pour une fois c'est ce que
craignaient les restaurateurs évidemment
la sphère de la jauge apparemment ça
restera ainsi en revanche fermeture des
discothèques ça c'est un petit peu le
coup dur on imagine pour les
discothèques yvon refermer encore une
fois pendant quatre semaines la réaction
en tout cas sur ces mesures globalement
effectivement c'est compliqué pour nos
amis les discothèques mais aussi très
compliqué pour les restaurants parce
qu'effectivement pas de jauge pour les
restaurants mais si une fermeture
déguisée des restaurants également des
bars et des hôtels puisqu'on nous dit
repassons télétravail trois jours par
semaine plus de moments festifs dans les
entreprises plus de réunions en
présentiel ont relevé luc distanti l on
sait que le mois de décembre est un mois
propice dans nos établissements à des
dépôts a des tas d'initiatives à des
réunions donc là on enlève tout ça donc
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire que 70 %
des restaurateurs ont des cascade
d'annulations les hôtels également aux
45 % d'annulations de chambre donc pour
nous c'est une fermeture déguisée de
nous teaser nous et pardonnez moi parce
que je ne vais pas vous mentir j'étais
aussi à l'antenne quand il ya eu ces
annonces il n'y a pas de réelle
contrainte c'est une limitation plus
sous la forme d'un d'un conseil n'est ce
pas d'éviter les interactions sociales
est une fermeture ce qui me fermeture
déguisée parce qu'en fait je peux vous
dire que depuis quatre jours nous avons
des cascade d'annulations dans nos
établissements donc on demande la
reprise du quoi qu'il en coûte et de
nouveau d'avoir des êtres dans nos
établissements parce que la cites une
fermeture déguisée on dit aux gens
n'allaient pas dans les restaurants
n'allez pas dans les bars c'est
dangereux vous pouvez attraper le comité
donc certes on peut le comprendre pour
pour la pour des mesures sanitaires pour
la santé du pays mais à côté de ça pour
mettre en place le quoi qu'il en coûte
alors docteur il ya eu plusieurs
réactions évidemment sur cette fermeture
des discothèques pour le président de
lumière l'homologue de notre ami
monsieur delvaux illumine nuit cette
fois la fermeture des discothèques ne
changera rien car les gens vont se ruer
dans les bars pour mathieu lebrun g en
discothèque avec ou sans nous la
jeunesse fera la fête et va se
contaminer tout autant et enfin stéphane
manigold président du groupe éclore un
fait de société de boîte de nuit par
dont la santé est primordiale mais la
santé des chefs d'entreprise est aussi
importante sur ces deux remarques ça
sert à rien parce que les gens vont
aller faire la fête ailleurs c'est pas
vraiment faux une jeunesse qui a été
muselé pendant deux ans on va pas les
arrêter là non vous avez raison donc ça
n'est pas l'essentiel des mesures
l'essentiel à nouveau c'est la
vaccination c'est à dire la troisième
dose c'est la totalité des adultes et la
vaccination des enfants qui doit débuter
le plus rapidement possible c'est ça les
mesures importantes en termes de santé
publique mais à côté de ça il ya les
mesures barrières et je crois que le
gouvernement essentiellement de table
sur la pédagogie la responsabilisation
mais il est vrai qu'il faut donner un
signal quand même que malheureusement
nous sommes dans une période difficile
et c'est vrai que quand on sait que
malheureusement la nuit dans des
établissements où les gens s'entassent
ou peut-être le système d'aération n'est
pas optimale ou surtout les gens
consomment de l'alcool et donc perdre un
peu le sens réel des choses et bien il y
à des contaminations il y a des
attitudes à risque et de fait cette
décision a été prise mais à nouveau je
ne crois pas que ce soit l'essentiel des
mesures quand vous entendez franck
delvaux nous dire voilà annonce une
catastrophe parce que c'est vrai qu'on
dissuader les gens de se réunir dans les
endroits publics les restaurants - de
convivialité pour noël ça nous semble
être vraiment nécessaire parce que on
nous dit voilà on nous pousse à la
vaccination et ça suffit toujours pas je
suis d'accord effectivement on va dire
on vit une période difficile maintenant
les restaurants peuvent fonctionner les
scilly allez on va dire les les
consignes sanitaires habituels sont bien
appliquées le risque d'être contaminé
est quand même faible
malgré tout effectivement si on laissait
les choses progresser sans contrôle eh
bien on risquerait d'avoir un
effondrement de l'hôpital incapables de
prendre en charge les patients et donc
de fait d'imposer un confinement strict
et c'est ce qu'on veut éviter par des
mesures de prévention qui permettraient
d'éviter cette situation malgré tout il
faut dire que très clairement l'épidémie
va atteindre son pic la de la cinquième
vague d'ici une quinzaine de jours il ya
un ralentissement de la vitesse de
progression de l'épidémie et donc ces
mesures qui sont pas si restrictives de
sa devront accompagner cette régression
de l'épidémie et on l'espère à pour un
plateau haut parce que c'est ça le
problème c'est que si l'épidémie
régressé vicomte se resituer sur un
plateau coup comme l'année passée eh
bien on risquerait cette fois-ci de
noyer l'hôpital qui n'a plus les moyens
de faire face à l'afflux de patients
ayant lakovic 19 nicolas l'eni on arrive
bientôt à la fin de notre débat une
mesure qui a changé enfin c'est pas
d'hier ça date de quelques jours déjà on
ne ferme plus les classes son premier 4
cos vide on teste et on isole ceux qui
sont positifs en tant que parent votre
réaction à la dessus
je ne suis pas du tout contre que
d'avancer essentiel que les classes
restent ouverts ensuite effectivement on
lutte on participe à la lutte contre la
propagation du virus mais je peux pas
laisser dire que ce sont les enfants qui
contamine les adultes ça c'est pas
possible
aujourd'hui c'est que le lait vaccin ne
protège pas contre la contamination est
ce qui protège le mieux contre la
comptabilisation malheureusement c'est
d'être touchés par le virus et
aujourd'hui quand vous avez 50 mille
personnes par jour ils sont touchés vous
avez aussi des gens qui du coup seront
viabilisés c'est pas n'importe quoi que
de dire ça ça a été des stratégies
conscient qu'un nombre de pays comme la
suède et aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas toute
cette population d'enfants qui souffrent
énormément
du fait de mesures sanitaires
s'ils sont pas utiles pour eux en tout
cas le petit je ne parle pas des
adolescents la discussion est différente
et pour les petits ce n'est pas utile
pour ils ne sont pas mal depuis le début
de la pandémie il ya eu trois enfants
décédés du cog hill avec de la
comorbidité donc voilà toutes ces
mesures prises à l'encontre des enfants
ce n'est pas dans leur intérêt il faut
très vite très vite leur permet de
revivre normalement sinon d'un point de
vue sociétal serait une catastrophe ça
l'est déjà plus franck devant le mot de
la fin pour pour vous aujourd'hui dans
quel état d'esprit êtes-vous on l'a
compris entier vous demander la
poursuite du quoi qu'il en coûte il
n'empêche on justement que les français
ressorte en tout cas c'est ce qu'on voit
dans les rues d'aider des grandes villes
en tout cas pour paris on a vu des
stations ce qui peut également se
remplir à nouveau comment vous sentez
les prochaines semaines de votre côté
c'est un petit passage difficile et ça
ira mieux après où les français andra
lanta
non les français ont peur on leur fait
peur je peux vous dire que je vous le
redis on a d un taux d'annulation
extraordinaire depuis quelques jours et
ça va s'amplifier dès demain donc
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
venez au restaurant veulent et quand
même au restaurant parce qu'on a un
protocole sanitaire très strictes je
rappelle que notre personnel est
également vaccinés on contrôler les
passes sanitaires mais à côté de ça il
faut que le gouvernement assume ces
mesures et puis remettant tout remettre
en fonction de quoi qu'il en coûte pour
les hôtels les restaurants et les bars
merci pourquoi tous les 3 bruno mais
garvan nicolas lang
mick franck pardon delvaux merci d'avoir
été avec nous pour réagir aux annonces
donc de ce soir restez avec nous